can i ask you
about jiu jitsu by all means
what have you learned from being a
practitioner you're a black belt
what have you learned from this journey
of being a martial artist
jiu jitsu for me was the connective
tissue
that started to join my mind together
with all the f different aspects of my
life
and so jiu jitsu for me was was really
important and i don't think i would be
doing anything that i'm doing right now
if it wasn't for jiu jitsu
so there's various aspects of my life
that
were in existence but i didn't
understand how they were connected until
i started training jiu-jitsu
the primary things are interacting with
other human beings
and combat tactics
and strategy and jiu jitsu and all those
things are connected
they all follow the same guiding
principles and i wouldn't have
recognized those guiding principles
if i didn't do jiu jitsu
can you elaborate because you've trained
for many many years
what uh is it the hardship is it the
humbling nature of just being tapped all
over
you know non-stop i don't i actually
don't know how many times
i've tapped more times than you okay so
good
is it just the hardship of physical
training like the honesty of the mat in
the sense that like
you know what works and what doesn't
work which which aspects were the most
uh impactful for you all aspects so yes
from
a humility perspective when you realize
you think
when you think you know what you're
doing when you think you have certain
skills
and you realize that there's always
somebody better than you and you realize
that hey maybe i don't have all the
answers all the time
and you bring that to a leadership
perspective and you walk into your
platoon and you realize that maybe you
don't have
all the answers all the time and maybe
you should listen to what other people
have to say
you bring that to a combat situation and
you realize that you think
if you sit there and think that you're
smarter than the enemy you're going to
be
complacent you're going to make mistakes
so there's
one aspect out of the gate as far as
you know if i if i'm going to try and
get your arm
do i attack your arm
maybe not directly unless i'm a white
belt exactly
what do i do i attack your neck and when
you reach up to defend your neck
that's when i get your arm well if i'm
out on the battlefield
and there's an enemy position should i
attack frontal assault into that
position
no no i shouldn't i should put down some
covering fire and i should maneuver
around to the flank it's the same thing
if i'm dealing with you and you're my
boss and you've got a giant ego
and you've come up with a plan and i
don't like your plan should i walk up to
you and say
hey lex your plan isn't good no or
should i say
hey lex can i ask you some questions
about how you want us to execute this
because
i want to make sure i understand your
vision
[Laughter]
so all these things are connected yes
and i wouldn't have realized that
that we could sit here and do this
forever we could we could i could tell
you these comparisons forever
but this all this connective tissue
bringing all these things together
i wouldn't have seen it without i don't
think i would have seen it without
jiu-jitsu
so jiu-jitsu to me had it had a
incredible life impact on me
not look the physical part yes
absolutely does it
does it keep you humble when you know
that there's a 145 pound individual
that can tap you out when you're 220
pound
25 year old guy and there's a 135 or 140
pound
you know 46 year old guy that can make
you tap out
that's humbling and and what do you do
with that
do you run away from it or do you
continue to pursue it
same thing with life same thing with
anything so jiu jitsu
is an incredibly powerful not just
physical
aspect but it's it's a way to understand
it's a way of thinking
you've also competed is there something
you can speak to the value of
competition
obviously you've been through combat
actual military combat is many many
many orders of magnitude more high
stakes
than competition in this in a silly
sport like jiu jitsu
nevertheless it still
has some of the echoes of the same
challenges
is there something you can speak to the
value of competition for you
yep competition will reveal weaknesses
in your game that you
can then go back and train to rectify
so that that's very useful to sort of uh
yeah
as a testing ground of course training
can be that testing ground as well uh or
um
that feedback yeah but as you and i both
know if you and i train together all the
time
you know my game i'll know your game and
even if we have five other people we all
kind of understand each other's games
and you're not doing something to me
that i don't expect so when i go
and compete i'm good you're you know
this random person
has a game that i've never seen before
i'm and i may or may not
know how to deal with that game if i
know how to deal with it great
i get the victory maybe i don't learn as
much if i don't know how to deal with
their game
i get the loss and i get the win
of learning what some weakness in my
game is
you